what's going on everybody welcome to
another open CV with Python tutorial
video where we left off we were
filtering for a specific color you can
imagine there's a lot of different
filters that you might apply may not
even be for a specific color where you
apply the filter but you still have a
lot of background noise and later on
when we do like foreground extraction or
background extraction the same thing
happens you wind up still with a little
bit of noise around just things are
moving or whatever falsely detected and
so on so you need to have some way to be
able to remove noise so first we'll be
talking about really simplistic ways
like smoothing and blurring to get rid
of noise and then we'll continue talking
about in the subsequent tutorial how to
even further get rid of noise in
different types of noise so so anyways
let's go ahead get started let me grab
my head again and so right now we have
the following
we've got just the the regular frame the
mask in the resolution we don't really
or the result we don't need to we could
probably keep masks just because it's
easy to see the background stuff
actually but we'll probably just keep
doing the result instead and we'll stop
displaying masks but anyway that's what
we're dealing with so far
so let's say you want to just apply like
a really simple blur basically and
that's you can basically do this with
averaging the pixels so um I said we'd
stop label set up a display masks
because we got so many things for
displaying feel free to like only
display frame or only to spray the
display the one thing we're working on
like if you're having trouble with lag
or something like that so to do
averaging it's relatively simple we're
going to make a kernel and the kernel
will be numpy ones just a list of ones
basically 15 by 15 datatype numpy float
32 and it's going to be so it's 15 by 15
and then we divide it by whatever this
number times this number is in RK is 15
times 15 - 25
so that I make an average of 15 by 15
pixels okay you can go smaller you can
say five by five and that would be 25
okay so that's your kernel and then we
apply that kernel by saying smooth
equals CV to filter 2d and then we're
gonna say res negative one and calm so
this will just apply like a simple
average basically of our frame oh we
need to display it almost made the same
mistake as before
okay so pay space good to go all right
so we actually I mean with this we
basically have no background noise but I
see a few little specks back there but
obviously it gets rid of a lot but we
also lose a lot of clarity so it's kind
of a bummer so we close this and we we
assign and that's not really the best
right and that's okay so now we're going
to talk about another form and that will
be a Gaussian blur so we'll just do it
right underneath here and we're going to
say blur blur blur is equal to CB -
Gaussian blur
we're going to apply it to that results
this - will be a 15 by 15 in n0
and then we need to show it so let's
copy that paste and blur and blur that
and it even though it's like the same
kind of size you should see this one's a
lot clearer more clear than the other
blur or average basically was so there's
that option my favorite though for
clarity is what's called this median
blur so median will be equal to cv -
median blur and we apply this to the
results and it's a 15 of size so then
we're going to call this
paced medium meaning run that and at
least here especially at a distance like
if you backup and this thing is small
like smaller on the frame you should
notice that it almost like we can make
it disappear and and I guess I mean
that's just what's happening as opposed
as you move it back it just doesn't want
to show up I guess it's like falling out
of the range that I specified probably
but if we hold it like nice and close
this one is the best as far as internal
noise is concerned there's really no
noise happening whereas there's a lot of
noise happening over there and it's of
course being returned in that blur but I
happen to like this one the best just
simply because it's the least noisy so
anyway there's that and then finally
there is a bilateral blur it's just
another version of blurring so bilateral
equals CV to bilateral filter apply to
the res 15 then we'll choose a 75 by 75
and then see what call CB TM show down
here just for the different versions of
blurs okay so in my opinion the
bilateral blur really is pretty much
useless it got rid of a little bit of
noise but not really so okay so anyways
those are the various blurs that you
have and I suppose a smooth that you
have at your disposal but a lot of times
that's just simply not going to be
enough so in the next tutorial we're
going to be talking about as
morphological transformations and what
that's going to allow us to do is is
remove noise and a bit better of a
method so anyway that's we're gonna be
covering this tutorial if you have
questions comments concerns or whatever
up to this point feel free to let me
know below otherwise as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions in its seal next time